bien estamos en el problema número 17 y
ya no suena el teléfono así que creo que
vamos bien por aquí y tenemos una
gráfica así que voy a intentar hacer la
gráfica de esta función que creo que me
va a ser muy importante tengo por aquí
mi ejes leyes es algo por acá y después
por aquí tengo mi eje x ok por aquí
tengo mi eje x y vamos a poner este es
el eje de las íes ok este es el eje x y
tengo la gráfica de una cierta función
que voy a poner de color a amarillo
tengo una función parecida a ésta una
función que va por aquí llega a este
punto a algo así y después baja
y después sube sube para acá perfecto ok
y me dan unos ciertos puntos muy
importantes
me dicen que este punto de aquí este
punto de aquí es el punto 0 1 0 1 y me
dicen que este punto de aquí este es el
punto 10 ok y además me dicen que esta
función de amarillo le ponen nombre a
esta función de amarillo le ponen el
nombre de e igual a fx y es igual a ftx
y lo que nos preguntan es lo que
queremos saber es cómo se ve la gráfica
de f de x + 2 como se ve la gráfica de x
+ 2 en mis siguientes incisos y bueno
para esto
lo que se me ocurre es no complicarnos
mucho la vida y voy a decir que quede x
le voy a cambiar de nombre a esto voy a
decir que eje x
gd x es igual a efe de x2 para no
confundirnos suficiente con todas las
jefes de este problema
y vamos a hacer una tabla vamos a hacer
una tabla porque esta tabla va a ser muy
importante
déjame poner este y aquí voy a hacer una
pequeña tabla en donde voy a poner aquí
a equis y primero voy a analizar a fx
que es la gráfica que me dan a fx fíjate
bien nos dicen que cuando x vale 0 f x
vale 1 y cuando x vale 1 f x vale 0
estos son los datos que me dan estos dos
puntos ahora qué va a pasar si nosotros
analizamos ag de x es más vamos a poner
aquí otra tabla voy a poner a x a x voy
a poner aquí a gd x y su correspondiente
f x es decir voy a poner aquí a x voy a
poner por acá
x a gd x y bueno gtx nosotros sabemos
que es lo mismo que f de x + 2 ok
ahora yo sé cómo se comporta la función
fx yo sé que cuando la función fx le
pongo aquí adentro cero
entonces me da el valor de 1 y si ahora
yo tengo efe de x + 2 bueno si yo lo que
quisiera hacer es esta parte de aquí
adentro 0 es decir nosotros sabemos que
f de cero
efe de cero es igual a 1 esto es lo que
sabemos justo por esta tabla de aquí
efe de cero es igual a 1 ahora sí gtx
está definida de esta forma quede x es
lo mismo que efe de x + 2 entonces yo lo
que voy a buscar es poner aquí adentro
un cero porque yo sé que cuando lo que
está dentro del paréntesis se hace cero
efe de cero es igual a 1 pero para que
lo que está dentro del paréntesis se
haga 0 necesitamos que en este caso x
valga menos 2 porque menos dos más dos
es ser es decir que en el caso en el que
x vale menos 27 x que es fx2 va a valer
1 porque porque me quedaría
de menos 2 que dé menos 2 esto es
exactamente lo mismo que f de 0 por qué
pues porque tendrían menos 2 más 2 lo
cual es 0 y nosotros sabemos que f de 0
por esta tabla de aquí es 1 am espero
que más o menos vaya quedando claro esto
lo que estoy haciendo es anulando la
parte de adentro de fx más 2 porque
nosotros ya tenemos el dato de que ft 0
es 1 en vez de cero es 1 por lo tanto si
la nueva función gtx está definida como
f de x + 2 entonces lo que voy a buscar
es que la parte de adentro se haga 0 y
la parte de adentro se hace 0 si x vale
menos 2 espero que vaya quedando un poco
más claro ahora que otro dato tengo yo
tengo el dato de f1
efe de 1 vale 0
de 10 esto es lo que me dice esta tarde
aquí que cuando yo pongo a x por 1
obtengo el 0 y bueno utilizando ahora
esta nueva expresión de gx gdx es igual
a efe de x + 2 ahora lo que voy a buscar
es que lo que está dentro del paréntesis
se haga 1 es decir que x + 2 se haga 1 y
x + 2 se hace uno si x vale menos 1 si x
vale menos uno tendría menos 12 lo cual
es 1 y ya sé que f de 1 es cero por lo
tanto g de menos 1 es exactamente lo
mismo que entre 1 que es 0 utilizando la
misma lógica si yo sé que f1 es cero
efe uno es cero entonces aquí lo que voy
a buscar es que esta parte de aquí
adentro se haga uno para que yo pueda
obtener el valor de cero el valor que a
mí me dan y por lo tanto estoy diciendo
que f de menos uno menos uno más dos me
da uno esto es igual a cero
y ahora mi pregunta es cómo se va a ver
la gráfica gtx am y déjenme cambiar de
color la voy a poner con color verde la
voy a poner con color verde a esta de
aquí la voy a graficar y vamos a ver qué
me queda yo sé que cuando x vale menos 2
gdx que es lo mismo que fx + 2 va a
valer 1 cuando x vale menos 2 a menos 1
- 2
entonces g de menos 2 es 1 es uno estoy
justo en este punto de aquí este punto
de aquí es el punto menos 2,1 ok esto es
lo que yo sé por una parte por otra
parte yo sé que cuando x vale menos 1 f1
que es lo mismo que quede menos 1 vale 0
o dicho otra manera cuando x vale menos
1 g de que es lo mismo que fx + 2 vale
cero es decir estoy en este punto de
aquí aquí estoy en el punto menos 10 ok
y si te das cuenta estas dos gráficas
deben de tener la misma forma por lo
tanto creo que ya puedo dibujar la
gráfica
deje de x la gráfica deje de x se va a
ver más o menos así sigue teniendo la
misma forma va a llegar aquí después va
a bajar para acá y después va a obtener
una misma recta muy parecida a ésta a
algo más o menos así va a obtener una
recta paralela a esta perfecto esa de
aquí es que de x que es efe de x + 2 de
lujo esta de aquí es g de x perfecto y
si te das cuenta lo único que pasó fue
que movimos a la gráfica f x 2 unidades
hacia la izquierda desplazamos a la
función f x 2 unidades en la izquierda
la movimos y seguramente tú debes decir
esto es muy raro porque yo tengo kg de x
es lo mismo que f de x + 2 y cuando yo
le sumó 2 en lugar de irse a la derecha
se va a la izquierda pero entonces ya
podemos usar un poco la lógica es decir
a ver si 7 x es esto que por cierto es
esta gráfica de aquí
mi respuesta yo lo que quiero
preguntarte es cómo se vería no sé efe
de x 2 f x menos 2 ahora es mi pregunta
y bueno usando la misma lógica lo que
vamos a hacer es recorrer esta gráfica
pero ahora dos unidades hacia la derecha
12 aquí va a tocar a mí ya que es las x
12 y por aquí vamos estar en el valor de
1 y entonces se vería más o menos así se
vería una gráfica que llegaría hasta
este punto y bajaría por acá y después
mantendría una recta por acá parecida a
ésta exactamente si nosotros restamos 2
se mueve a la derecha y si nosotros
sumamos 2 se mueve hacia la izquierda
pero la gráfica es la misma en este caso
no estaríamos moviendo hacia la derecha
muy bien ahora esta es la moraleja que
quiero dejarte en este ejercicio si tú
entiendes bien qué es lo que está
pasando con la gráfica no en función si
nosotros nos tomamos efe de x + 2 o efe
de x menos 2 o de cualquier constante
entonces ya me voy a dar por bien
servido en este ejercicio
lo que quiero que entiendas es que
cuando nosotros tomamos efe de x + una
constante esto se desplaza hacia la
izquierda y si nosotros nos tomamos efe
de x menos una constante esto se
desplaza hacia la derecha y de igual
manera creo que alguna vez llega hasta
ver o de hecho está mucho más fácil
pensar quién es igual a efe de x + 2
efe de x + 2 bueno pues esto se vería
como en la misma gráfica déjame hacerla
como por aquí se vería como la misma
gráfica pero la voy a desplazar dos
unidades hacia arriba ahora lo que
tendríamos sería una gráfica parecida a
ésta tendríamos en lugar de que corta el
1 se vería algo por acá bajaría una
unidad por acá y después se movería para
acá sería la misma gráfica solamente que
se desplazaría hacia arriba dos unidades
dos unidades muy bien bueno esto es un
repaso de funciones y me gustó mucho
este problema pero vamos a hacer el
siguiente problema el problema número 18
así que voy a borrar todo esto que tengo
aquí ok y vamos a poner por aquí el
problema número
espero no haberlo confundido mucho y
bueno se me estaba olvidando a decir que
en el ejercicio pasado la respuesta
correcta es la hace el inciso c es la
gráfica que se parece más a la gráfica
que nosotros dibujamos pero ahora
estamos en este problema 18 y tengo un
triángulo de nuevo tengo una cierta
gráfica por así decirlo pero en esta
ocasión tengo triángulos y esto se
parece un poco al juego de los ángulos
vamos a ver que me sale tengo un
triángulo como este este triángulo de
aquí que por cierto se llama abc y
adentro de éste tengo otro triángulo
ahorita le ponemos nombres porque
parecido a este y este triángulo se
llama d
es más pongamos los nombres esto es el
triángulo
b c y después por aquí tengo d
a veces de él y aquí está efe esta es
que tan fea pero ya está componiendo
perfecto esta sed y que datos me dan me
dan a veamos
me dicen que helado ave helado ave es
igual al lado veces el lado ave es lo
mismo que el lado b c entonces vamos a
ponerlo así el lado ave es lo mismo que
el lado b c y si son iguales nosotros
sabemos que este ángulo este ángulo y
este ángulo son iguales los triángulos
que tienen dos lados iguales es decir
los triángulos isósceles cumplen que
estos dos lados también son iguales eso
ya lo sabemos vamos bien hasta aquí y
además me dicen que el triángulo de efe
es un triángulo equilátero es decir ante
el cambio de color que esta distancia es
lo mismo que esta distancia que es la
misma que está
distancia y los triángulos que son
equiláteros nosotros sabemos que este
ángulo mide 60 grados este ángulo de
aquí también mide 60 grados y este
ángulo de kim mide también 60 grados
porque todos los lados miden lo mismo y
todos los ángulos miden lo mismo y
además me dan otro dato me dicen si
nosotros sabemos que en este triángulo
el ángulo a veces vale 30 grados el
ángulo a veces van de 30 grados este de
aquí vale 30 grados 30 grados y por otra
parte nosotros sabemos que el ángulo
efe de el val 50 grados efe de este
ángulo vale 50 grados déjeme que me dio
color este ángulo vale 50 grados
entonces lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale el ángulo de f
cuánto vale el ángulo de f
de f este es el ángulo que nosotros
queremos saber y lo voy a poner como x
esto es lo que nosotros queremos saber
muy bien pues esencialmente tenemos un
juego de dos ángulos así que vamos a ver
qué podemos encontrar por aquí
lo primero que quiero que veas y lo
primero que puedo encontrar una manera
muy sencilla es este ángulo de aquí este
ángulo de aquí cuanto me ve bueno pues
está en un triángulo en donde uno de sus
ángulos mide 50 grados
el otro mide 30 grados y entonces cuánto
va a medir este de aquí bueno pues este
de aquí va a medir 180 menos 80 es decir
que este ángulo mide 100 grados 100
grados todos los ángulos de un triángulo
suman 180 180 menos 30 150 menos 50 es
100 este ángulo mide 100 grados perfecto
así que creo que vamos bien a que otra
cosa
bueno se me ocurre pensar que este
ángulo de aquí este ángulo de aquí
cuánto mide pues todos estos ángulos son
ángulos suplementarios son ángulos
suplementarios porque están dividiendo a
una misma línea recta por lo tanto la
suma de estos me debe dar 180 pero ya
llevo 50 y ya llevo 60 cuánto me falta
para llegar al 280 bueno 50 más 50 son
100 más 10 son 110 para 180 me sobran 70
este ángulo mide 70 grados porque porque
la suma de estos tres me dan 180 ok me
voy acercando poco a poco a este
y bueno cuánto vale este de aquí este de
aquí vale 100 más 60 es 160 para 180
éste mide 20 grados 20 grados ok ahora
que otra cosa puedo saber para obtener
el valor de x ya estamos muy cerca si
nosotros veamos este ángulo podríamos
obtener de una manera muy sencilla el
valor de x a y cuánto vale este
bueno pues fíjate bien si yo tengo este
triángulo y el triángulo a veces lo voy
a dibujar acá para que no te confundas
tengo el triángulo aquí así y después
tengo una base de color verde o algo así
y este es una escala de nuestro
triángulo
de c es un triángulo más pequeño porque
está hecho a escala pero en este
triángulo nosotros sabemos que este
ángulo mide 30 grados que es este de
aquí y por otra parte sabemos que este
ángulo y este ángulo miden lo mismo es
decir que si este ángulo mide 30 grados
entonces este estos dos ángulos se
tienen que repartir lo que le falta a 30
grados para llegar a 180 es decir que la
suma de estos dos ángulos me tienen que
dar 150 o dicho de otra manera cada uno
de estos ángulos tienen que ser 150
entre 2 porque estos dos ángulos son
iguales que estoy diciendo que si estos
dos ángulos son iguales entonces éste
debe de medir 75 grados éste debe de
medir 75 grados de tal manera que 75 más
75 m de 150 más 30 m de 180 perfecto ya
tenemos nueva información este ángulo
mide 75 grados y este de aquí también
mide 75 grados ok y ahora si puedo
obtener el valor de x quien es x
x + 75 grados más 70 grados es decir
este triángulo de aquí me estoy fijando
en este triángulo de kim esto tiene que
sumar 180 porque están adentro del mismo
triángulo y si esto es cierto entonces x
es lo mismo que 180 grados menos 70
grados grados grados menos 75 grados y
cuántos esto bueno pues me quedan aquí
110 110 menos 70 es lo mismo que 40 40
menos 5 es 35 35 grados
x debe de valer 35 grados que es justo
lo que yo quería x igual a 35 grados y
es el inciso b ya quedó perfecto y ya se
me acabó el tiempo voy a hacer es los
siguientes y últimos dos problemas de
esta sección en el siguiente vídeo que
por cierto si tú quieres corroborar que
estás bien pues podrías utilizar este
ángulo para ver que en efecto todo
concuerde y todo esté perfectamente bien
establecido así que no te pierdas
nuestro siguiente vídeo
y hasta la próxima